I want to talk about some lessons that I
have what I've learned and what you can
do with coronavirus right now so here
are the things oh I'm sorry I forgot
let's all get together and do our daily
ritual of hand sanitizer thank you very
much okay
tonight the first what I'm gonna do is
I'm gonna share some lessons and I want
to share some actual comments that I've
gotten from real business owners what
they're doing and you're gonna hear in
their voice some of them are distraught
some of them are hopeful some of them
don't know what to do so we're gonna
talk about all these situations and then
we're gonna do questions the first piece
of advice that I have for every business
owner out there is move get moving
accept reality and make a plan you've
got to in life so many times the common
thing we do when we're startled is we
freeze in business
freezing is death so the answer is to
move is to accept reality customers are
going away money may be drying up
nothing is gonna change and get better
overnight I can guarantee you that so
what are you going to do about it you
know I remember I always ask my friends
on their birthday what's your birthday
twisdom and you know usually I get these
text chains and friends are like make
time for what's important that's what
one of my co-workers recently said to me
one year when my business is going
through a large decline my answer to
this group of friends was it can always
get worse and that was something I
learned painfully which was you might
predict a 15% revenue decline but what
happens if it's 50 what happens if it's
50 percent two years ago what
you do about that when I say accept
reality and make a plan there's a couple
things that are really important for you
to know as a business owner first you
must believe that your business is
important you've got to believe it do
you know how many business owners are
writing you right now and saying I don't
know if I can sell my luxury good nobody
cares about that anymore and I want to
get your head on straight if you don't
believe in your business right now
then your customers will never believe
they can sniff it out and customers are
smart I've always believed that I'm
curious to know what do you think you
know opportunities are going to show up
in the next 30 days and what
opportunities are going to show up after
the crisis when things come back to
normal business you know stock market
real estate like you know what do you
see based on no experience yeah so I'll
give you the easy one so in terms of the
stock market obviously as the old adage
goes you want to buy when there's blood
in the streets and you want to sell when
everybody is jubilant and thinks that
it's going to last forever so that you
were in that time now so if you have the
capital to deploy then over the next few
weeks is probably gonna be a good time
to deploy that I wouldn't go crazy I
would not play a Wall Street vet
scenario I would be you know dollar-cost
averaging your way in I'd be buying and
slowly over time I'd be focused entirely
on indexes like I am so conservative
when it comes to playing the stock
market but I think that there will be
huge opportunities there I am certainly
not confident enough about the real
estate market to make any
prognostications I'll just give you my
logic so the way that I would think
about it is this if we're going through
a round of just like mass layoffs and
there's gonna be a huge impact to the
economy you'd need to be able to buy
what they call an alligator property for
and be able to hold it for a long period
of time now they're called alligator
properties because they are slowly
eating you alive because you may have to
carry something without having you know
rents coming in for quite a period of
time as things settle down but there's
no question if we're in an economic
depression and I hesitate to throw those
words around
if we're in a downturn if you know we're
in a correction however you want to
think about it but if prices have
normalized or gone down a bit it's
certainly a good time to pick things up
alright now in terms of business
opportunities that's going to be
dependent on what your business is so
that'll be unique to everybody what you
want to be looking out for is actually
identify what the changing dynamics are
where the the facts that are impacting
your business so this is a time where
you don't want to be dealing with things
emotionally you don't want to be looking
at things from a panic position you just
want to look at the facts and then where
do the facts lead you so I'll give you
an example
from a time of non sort of stress just a
reality of coming into a new business
and assessing what are the facts that
allowed me to see things that other
people weren't seeing so I come in to
the comic book market after you know
nearly a decade dealing with grocery
stores I understand distribution
incredibly well I come into the comic
book industry and it is very clear to me
that the distribution model is
fundamentally flawed like it's it's
broken at such a deep level and as an
outsider it was like people would invite
me to speak on panels and I would just
be looking around like hey we can all
agree right that this is completely free
and doesn't make any sense
and people are like yeah but there's
nothing that we can do about it and that
to me just seemed patently false
so looking at what are facts of the
industry okay facts of the industry
comic book sales have been declining for
years where are those people going
they're going to video games they're
going to video games is the biggest one
and then they're going online okay well
if we know that you're losing your
potential audience to video games mobile
devices then can you meet them there can
you either create a channel on twitch
where you're marketing your books
nobody's doing that can you instead of
trying to sell the book itself can you
use the book as a loss leader to
translate it into other media and that
means that it's what we call hashtag
steal this comic so we came into it and
said okay cool we're not gonna put all
of our time and resources into the
strategy of trying to sell a physical
book in a store because that's clearly
facts right the facts showed that that's
declining so where did the facts show
that something's happening well the
facts show that
you know of the I don't know the top 25
highest-grossing media properties of all
time something like 13 of them started
as a comic book so it's like crazy the
top 19 of the highest-grossing or sorry
the top 9 of the highest-grossing films
of all time were launched in the last 15
years and they're all Disney so it's
like you begin to see okay what's
working what's not working and how do I
build awareness which is what I really
need so yoga studios I've had a couple
of those pop off in the the feeds here
and they're asking the same question
which is hey how do I survive this
social distancing is a thing a yoga
studio is the exact opposite of that and
my answer is you're looking at the
problem in the wrong way so you're not
just addressing you're not addressing
the facts facts people can't be together
fact yoga doesn't have to be done in a
studio fact online is huge and allows
you to be global so the opportunity in a
yoga studio is to be teaching yoga
online so that's where like if you just
break this down like what are the facts
what's working what's not working forget
how it's always been done which is where
people run into a trap or this is my
skill set I know how to run a physical
yoga studio this is usually why
disruption happens from the outside
people cannot re-envision their own way
of doing things and because they can't
get out of their own way they can't
reimagine themselves they get stuck in a
trap and it's the person coming from the
outside who has just a totally different
picture of how things could be done they
see things that other people can't see
so as much as I hate to say it that's
really gonna be the name of the game
you've got to find a way to see what
other people can't see and the way
they're gonna do that's twofold number
one you have to stop being emotional you
have to let go of who you think you are
in the way that your business runs and
number two you just have to look at the
facts if the virus hits badly then won't
be the future of commodity metals
commodity metals so you know many metals
is precious metals there's semi precious
metals there's strategically important
metals for manufacturing these metals
that are acquired
defense medals that required two
medications medals are why for
Diagnostics there's all different types
of metal so medicines are very broad you
know blood you know commodity turn right
generally speaking what coronavirus is
going to do is suppress demand for
everything
give me a drop in demand over all the
goods and services the same thing
happens when there's tariffs that magic
tariff barriers being it's one people
with a tariff said that are really
economically wise they say tariffs could
lead to depressed activity economically
because you stopped people from trading
what's happening right now is social
isolation by definition means people
stop getting together and talking and
training whether if that's ideas
that's goods and services in person
right so economic activity slows down
well again economic tivity go back to
the beginning well manufacturing
requires what certain types of metals
where do those metals come from they
come from the ground ok and there's some
better stockpiles strategically most are
there certain amounts of stockpiling and
then given moment this X amount of raw
metal in various phases of production
and refinement as it gets made into the
finished product so there is this sort
of pipeline of any commodity of any
given moment but those old trade based
on what's called futures right there's
the future value that you and you see
the price it's a it's based on a future
value for delivery X date so this is all
about say okay well if I'm thinking of
buying a meadow you're not usually find
the physical metal you're buying a
futures contract on that metal and
people say well chances are in the
future the man is gonna be a lot lower
because everyone is staying inside no
one's buying anything
fear is reigning supreme right now the
cause of that the man drops the ban for
the metal drops so what happens when the
man drops the price drop so it's
probably gonna be somewhat bearish from
metals however then you have things that
are considered storehouses of value like
gold silver sometimes can be sued that
sound ok psa's where it's a precious
metal like gold right
that's a flight that quality people will
stop buying though because they're
losing
they in the economies of the world
meaning US dollar based which they live
in a dollar based world right so as it
moves faith in fiat currency they can
complete run to precious metals like
gold may that's what gold will rally in
times of uncertainty and that's proven
to be true in this particular case many
years ago in 2008 Warren Buffett said
America is on sale and right now when
the market hits to the bottom of where
it's going to end up today was the
single worst day in the markets history
and so when the market gets down to the
bottom there are certain companies that
are value businesses value companies
that I already own that I'm gonna get
and by morold and so I'm gonna
capitalize on the prices for what I
already thought was valuable being lower
and since I don't buy and sell today
this week this month I buy for the next
you know 5 10 15 20 years that's my
personal strategy now some people I have
an employee who's made you know 150
percent on his money in the last 10 days
that's not I don't want the risk which
means I'm not gonna get the reward and
so I'm at a different stage in my life
now where I don't need the risk I don't
want the risk I I like slow and steady
wins the race you know if I could double
my money every you know three or four
years and my investments I'm a happy
camper
every time you go off now you got to be
like no Corona Corona I just feel like
people definitely have to be conscious
right now it's not forever but if people
don't get conscious now it's gonna last
a lot longer
like to stay in the now like what's a
month or two of both just look at it
like a vacation but I just bills got to
get paid but I don't think anybody gonna
be stressing bills for three months you
know I'm a vodka noises if you want more
advice wisdom guidance from other
successful entrepreneurs on how you can
navigate the coronavirus situation check
out the video right
to me I hope you find it valuable
continue to believe and I'll see you
there
rather than retract ask yourself how can
you build your skills